swatting has been going on on Twitch for
over a decade now but just a week into
2024 and we've already gotten multiple
new victims it's been a consistent thorn
in the side of the streaming Community
but who is responsible for fixing it and
how do they even do
it okay we all know what swatting is by
now falsely reporting a threat to law
enforcement in the hopes of pulling a
heavily armed police presence to a
specific location
I think that's why I
did but I don't understand why we didn't
just one Raptor death that one mini
where's the
bum I'm holding mini peek bum's done by
T daps is a ramp player and Lex plays
he's Locker he's Locker stupid and
extremely dangerous on top of it costing
good old taxpayer money people and their
animals can and have been shot in the
past as a result of swatting in 2017 the
family of a Kansas man killed by police
during a swatting allegedly brought on
by a Call of Duty streaming Feud sought
out $25 million in Damages from the city
of Witchita for his death for as long as
twitch and other streaming platforms
have existed content creators on them
have been vulnerable to these types of
attacks God oh my God oh my God oh my
God
noo bro just for my safety just for my
safety just for my safety just for my
safety in in case anything happen no no
no no no no no
Sor you're on your
own
yeah after this
wait unfortunately the more you let your
audience in on your own personal life
the more likely it is a disturbed
individual is going to try and find out
where you live or where you are at any
given moment we have already seen this
manifest in some scary situations
including the stalker who broke into the
home of content creators Gavin Free and
Meg turny with a gun resulting in a
shootout with police that left the
perpetrator dead while the two hid in a
closet now this is obviously a very
extreme example of what can happen but
the point is in terms of swatting all
somebody needs is a location they're
clearing rooms what in the world I think
we're getting
swatted put your hands behind your
back and streamers have had to deal with
this for a very long time to the point
where people like xqc and Summit kind of
treat it like a daily chore even if we
don't hear about it it still happens
behind the scenes a lot of creators
simply don't mention it so as to not
give the caller the attention they so
desperately want however there are those
moments where it's impossible to keep
from the public and just a few days into
the new year we saw it happen at 6:30 in
the morning on January 4th Pro valerant
Player s was swatted by an unknown
person on the webcam we can see law
enforcement enter his room with guns
drawn to make matters worse s lives at
home with his family who were all
sleeping at the time now thankfully no
one was hurt but it's just a prime
example of how scary moments like these
can be now everyone is safe but that is
so I always knew that was a problem but
I didn't think it would happen to me but
Tom isn't the only one whose family has
been put in danger due to swatting this
year the following day Apex Legends Pro
Imperial Hal claimed that his parents
house in Florida was swatted while he
was Midstream in Texas and just
yesterday it happened again with another
streamer this time out in public point
is swatting is still a major issue and
although streamers are hardly the only
people that fall victim to this
someone's eventually going to get hurt
and potentially even on camera if it
keeps happening at this rate so the
question is who is responsible and what
can be done to stop it well firstly as I
said before this issue goes Way Beyond
the realm of streaming just a couple of
weeks ago several American politicians
reported being swatted in their homes
two representatives from Ohio said that
they believe they were targeted for
helping make swatting a felony in their
state now to get the obvious out of the
way the people to blame are the ones
doing this swatting at best they're
cowards and at worst they're deeply
troubled and to stop the issue it's up
to law enforcement to investigate and
hold them accountable in June of last
year the FBI announced the formation of
a National Database to track and prevent
swatting by sharing information across
hundreds of police departments but will
these measures protect the average
twitch streamer twitch has recognized
that since it takes place on their
platform they do bear some
responsibility for protecting their
users they have suggested that streamers
contact their local police department to
get put under a registry so that law
enforcement is aware of their situation
and can respond accordingly however
outside of educating craters on how to
secure their own personal information
and banning Bad actors there isn't much
that twitch can do that doesn't involve
more invasive tactics and as we know
even IP banss and two- Factor
authentication can be circumvented
unfortunately I don't think I have the
answer for this one I know the gut
reaction is to push for harsher and
harsher punishments but time and time
again it's shown that those don't work
in other areas of the law all I can
really say is that this all stems from
the parasocial relationship ships we
have with creators but honestly it feels
like the toothpaste is out of the tube
on that one with that I'll leave it with
you guys outside of the freaks who do it
who is responsible for preventing these
types of things from happening do
streamers need to be more careful does
twitch need to step up and protect their
money makers or are we actually
just I've never been swatted but when I
was 12 years old I had a BB gun fight uh
with my friends in a park of the street
and then someone from the apartment that
could look down that called like the
Special Response Unit whatever I think
that's what it's called and they didn't
have like their guns drawn or anything
but they like made us put all the BB
guns on the ground and they like took
pictures of them and then they're like
just go home and we went home